et on retrouve tout de suite katia pique
nique devant la cour d'assises de paris
katia est ce que les accusés ont pris la
parole durant les audiences tout à
l'heure
et oui absolument les accusés se sont
exprimés dans le cadre des enquêtes de
personnalité donc pas sur les faits mais
c'est l'occasion de les découvrir de
tenter de comprendre comment ses voisins
bienveillants et aidants jusqu'ici à
l'égard de mire et knoll ont pu basculer
dans la barbarie et la complicité alors
tout d'abord la mère de yacine nuke qui
aurait lavé le couteau après le meurtre
qui est donc la troisième mise en examen
elle a évoqué en fils alcoolique qui en
voulait à la terre entière et qui lui
pourrissait la vie et puis yacine miu
justement l'accusé qu'on n'accuse être
le cerveau de ce meurtre s'est exprimé
d'une voix claire posé il reconnaît la
dégradation c'est à dire l incendie qui
survenu dans l'appartement mais nie les
faits de vol ni les faits de meurtre
aggravé et puis il a surtout évoqué un
viol subi à l'âge de 12 ans dans
l'internât dans lequel il a suivi sa
scolarité avec une plante à la clé qui a
été déposée quelques années plus tard et
ce serait un traumatisme qui l'aurait
rendu amer et violent envers lui-même et
les autres délinquants il avait par
exemple l'habitude de voler toute sa
famille pour acheter de l'alcool ou de
la drogue et des addictions qui était
très présente mais qui selon lui ne le
rendait pas violent même si le tableau
général et celui de la violence alors
voir les accusés a évidemment beaucoup
peiné à la famille canal donc je vous
propose d'écouter le fils de mire et
knoll daniel que mal ainsi que l'avocat
de la famille knoll gilles william
goldnadel
est ce qu'on nous a décrit est tellement
horrible
revenir
c'est insupportable de les voir ici
c'est très difficile je me dis comment
des êtres humains
peuvent faire des choses pareilles je
n'attends pas grand chose d'eux se sont
ils sont bien trouvés tous les deux ce
sont deux menteurs patentés
c'est pas moi qui vous le dis quand vous
écoutez ce que disent leurs parents la
mère par exemple de yacine me home
ne cesse de dire que son que son fils
est un menteur donc comment voulez vous
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'attende
de quelqu un dans chaque mot qui sort de
sa bouche est un menteur et d'autre part
un éclairage particulier quand même de
ce genre de personne parce que bien sûr
ce sont des êtres humains mais on a
quand même à faire pas bon de vous le
dire comme ça à la lie à la lide
l'espèce humaine
alors il reste bien sûr des questions
sur le caractère antisémite de ce
meurtre qui vont peut être être
développées tout à l'heure il ya six
demi avait fait quelque temps avant à
cette agression à des recherches sur
l'islam salafiste ou les frères
musulmans et on a su aussi plus tard
lorsqu'il était en prison qu'ils avaient
tagué des inscriptions favorable aux
attentats de charlie hebdo et de l'hyper
cacher donc des éléments évidemment à
charge mais des éléments aussi il ya
aussi autre chose à investiguer bien sûr
c'est les versions contradictoires des
deux accusés qui se rejettent la faute
merci katia technique pour toutes
ces informations directes donc de la
cour d'assises de paris